FOR BOTH STATES COMING DOWN
FAIRLY SIGNIFICANTLY.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANKS SO MUCH.
WE GET UPDATES LIKE THAT EVERY
NIGHT FOR SEVERAL WEEKS AND
WE’VE DONE OUR BEST TO KEEP
UP-TO-DATE ON WHAT’S HAPPENING
IN THIS PANDEMIC.
THE PAST FEW DAYS THE TRUTH HAS
SEEMED LIKE A SWIFTLY MOVING
TARGET.
SOME OF THE BIG NUMBERS HAVE
BEEN CHANGING MOST DAY BY DAY
AND OTHERS APPEAR TO CONTRADICT
EACH OTHER.
IN OTHER CASES, INFORMATION JUST
AS INCOMPLETE AND WON’T BE FOR A
WHILE.
IT’S ALL HAPPENING VERY FAST.
AT THIS POINT A COUPLE OF TRENDS
ARE COMING INTO FOCUS.
FIRST, AN AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE GETTING SICK FROM THIS
ILLNESS, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
NEW INFECTIONS EVERY DAY AND
SOME OF THEM ARE DYING.
IT’S HORRIFYING TO WATCH.
BUT THERE’S ALSO A BRIGHTNESS ON
THE HORIZON, A FORECAST THAT
MANY OF US DID NOT EXPECT.
ESTIMATES ON THE FINAL DEATH
TOLL HAVE BEEN REVISED
DRAMATICALLY DOWNWARD AND
DR. TONY FAUCI ACKNOWLEDGED AS
MUCH TODAY.
>> DO YOU THINK THE NUMBER OF
FATALITIES IN THIS COUNTRY WILL
BE SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN THE
100000-240,001ST PROJECTED?
>> I DO.
I BELIEVE WE ARE GOING TO SEE A
DOWNTURN IN THAT AND IT LOOKS
MORE LIKE THE 60,000 BENZO
HUNDRED OR 200,000.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT WE BETTER
BE CAREFUL THAT WE DON’T SAY WE
ARE DOING SO WELL THAT WE CAN
PULL BACK.
>> Tucker: 60,000 DEATHS IS A
VERY BIG NUMBER.
IF SOMEONE YOU LOVE IS AMONG
THEM IT’S EVERYTHING.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME IT’S FAR
FEWER THAN MANY EXPECTED.
IT’S A MUCH LOWER NUMBER AND WE
WANT TO BE AS HONEST AS WE CAN
ABOUT THIS.
THEN WE PREDICTED ON THIS SHOW
FOR EXAMPLE, THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE CASES WHERE WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO BE WRONG.
NOT JUST WRONG ABOUT THE DEATH
TOLL BUT THE NUMBER OF INFECTED
PATIENTS WHO NEED TO BE
HOSPITALIZED HAS ALSO BEEN WAY
BELOW EARLY ESTIMATES.
WE FEARED THAT A MASSIVE WAVE OF
DESPERATE PEOPLE STRUGGLING TO
BREATHE WOULD OVERWHELM HER
HEALTH, HOSPITALS AND BREAK OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, THAT WAS A
PRIMARY CONCERN.
BUT SO FAR IT HASN’T HAPPENED.
INSTEAD SOMETHING COMPLETELY
UNEXPECTED APPEARS TO BE TAKING
PLACE.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, HEALTH CARE
WORKERS ARE BEING LET GO OR
FURLOUGHED.
ELECTIVE PROCEDURES HAVE BEEN
CANCELED AND THAT MEANS THERE IS
NO PATIENCE FOR THEM TO CARE
FOR.
HOSPITALS ARE RUNNING SHORT ON
CASH.
IN NEW YORK CITY AND ENTIRE
HOSPITAL HAS BEEN CLOSE EXCEPT
ITS EMERGENCY ROOM.
ELSEWHERE, HOSPITALS ARE SITTING
HALF EMPTY OR EMPTY THANKS TO A
LOCKDOWN MEANT TO EASE PRESSURE
ON HOSPITALS.
THAT’S A STORY NONE OF US
EXPECTED TO SEE.
IT’S ALL PRETTY SHOCKING GIVEN
WHAT WE HAD SUSPECTED BUT THE
WEIRDEST THING OF ALL IS HOW
LITTLE ATTENTION THIS IS ALL
GETTING.
IN A CRISIS NOTHING IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN STAYING CONNECTED
TO REALITY.
FACTS CHANGE VERY FAST AND IT’S
EASY TO MISS THEM.
INSTEAD YOU GET TRAPPED IN A
STORY LINE THAT YOU CREATED
WEEKS OR MONTHS BEFORE WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY A TEMPTATION IN THE
NEWS BUSINESS.
BUT THAT’S HOW TERRIBLE
DECISIONS GET MADE.
THE PEOPLE DON’T LOOK UP LONG
ENOUGH TO NOTICE THEIR
ASSUMPTIONS WERE WRONG.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT MIGHT BE
HAPPENING NOW.
SOME CASES THE PEOPLE PAID TO
BRING YOU THE VERY LATEST NEWS
SEEM UTTERLY IGNORANT OF WHAT’S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING AND THEY
DEEPLY RESENT ANY ATTEMPTS TO
BRING THEM UP TO SPEED.
WATCH THIS MSNBC NEWS READER
SCHOOLED WHO DARE SUGGEST THAT
OBSERVABLE REALITY HAS CHANGED
IN ANY WAY FROM TWO WEEKS AGO.
>> LET’S MAKE SOMETHING CLEAR.
OPEN FOR BUSINESS IS A
SENTIMENT, IT’S A SIGN.
IT’S NOT REAL LIFE.
THIS ISN’T A SNOW DAY, WE ARE
GOING TO DECIDE A WEEK FROM NOW
OR THREE WEEKS FROM NOW,
ALL RIGHT, EVERYONE TRACKED BACK
TO WORK.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBER IT’S
UPSETTING AND IT’S JARRING BUT
IT ALSO MEANS THAT AMERICANS ARE
GOING HOME WHICH IS WHAT WE NEED
THEM TO DO.
THINK ABOUT IT.
IF HE’S MENTIONING THIS TO
PEOPLE IN THE AGATE COMMUNITY,
IF YOU RUN A FARM YOU CANNOT RUN
THE RISK THAT THE PEOPLE YOU
HAVE OUT THERE WORKING HAVE THE
VIRUS AND ARE SPREADING IT TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
THIS IS VERY SERIOUS BUSINESS
AND A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHERE
THE STOCK MARKET AND REAL LIFE,
AND THE REAL ECONOMY, ARE TWO
VERY DIFFERENT THINGS.
>> Tucker: SOLD 17 MILLION
PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED IS ACTUALLY A
POSITIVE SIGN, THEY ARE TELLING
YOU.
THAT MEANS THAT AMERICANS ARE
DOING "WHAT WE NEED TO DO."
IF YOU FIND YOURSELF SAYING
SOMETHING LIKE THAT OUT LOUD,
PAUSE FOR A MOMENT AND LISTEN TO
YOUR OWN WORDS, IT MEANS YOU’VE
LOST PERSPECTIVE.
IN THIS SPECIFIC CASE WE SHOULD
GIVE EVERYONE THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT.
AMERICANS ARE TIRED AND FEARFUL
AND FRAYED FROM WEEKS OF
UNCERTAINTY AND SADNESS BUT THAT
DOES NOT ELIMINATE OUR
OBLIGATION TO THINK AS CLEARLY
AS WE CAN BECAUSE AT SOME POINT
WE HAVE TO PIVOT FROM OUR
CURRENT LOCKDOWN TO WHATEVER
COMES NEXT AND NOW IS A TIME TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT MEANS.
IT’S NOT ENOUGH TO HARANGUE THE
PUBLIC ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
IMMORAL IF THEY DON’T LIKE TO BE
SHOT INSIDE ALL DAY, THAT’S THE
EASY PATH RIGHT NOW AND NOT
SURPRISINGLY THAT’S WHAT A LOT
OF OUR POLITICIANS ARE DOING.
BUT THE COUNTRY DESERVES MORE
OBVIOUSLY.
WE HAVE TO BE WORKING HARD TO
DETERMINE WHICH PARTS OF
AMERICAN LIFE CAN RETURN TO
NORMAL, WHICH CANNOT, AND WHEN?
HOW DO YOU MOVE A NATION OF
320 MILLION PEOPLE FROM
ISOLATION AND JOBLESSNESS BACK
TO SOMETHING BETTER?
YOU DON’T HEAR MANY PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT THAT IN ANY DETAIL
BUT YOU SHOULD BE.
SO WE ARE GOING TO START.
GOING FORWARD WE HOPE TO BE A
FORM ON HOW ALL GOOD IDEAS ON
HOW TO BRING AMERICA BACK AND
BUY GOOD IDEAS WINNING SENSIBLE,
SAFE AND INCREMENTAL SOLUTIONS.
THIS IS A COMPLEX MOMENT AND YOU
SHOULD BE AWARE OF ANYONE WHO
CLAIMS TO FIX IT WITH THE
SLOGAN, THAT’S IMPOSSIBLE.
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE ALREADY WELL
DOWN THIS ROAD.
NEXT WEEK THE AUSTRIAN
GOVERNMENT WILL ALLOW MOST SMALL
BUSINESSES TO REOPEN.
HAIR SALONS AND SHOPPING MALLS
WILL FOLLOW IN EARLY MAY.
THE AUSTRIANS ARE BEING CAREFUL
ABOUT THIS AND OF COURSE THEY
SHOULD BE.
STORES ARE BEING TOLD TO LIMIT
HOW MANY PATRONS COME INSIDE AT
ONCE, WEARING MASKS INSIDE
GROCERY STORES AND PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION WILL BE
MANDATORY.
TRAVEL WILL BE SHARPLY
RESTRICTED FOR SOME TIME.
AMERICA IS NOT AUSTRIA, WE CAN’T
COPY EVERY MOVE THE AUSTRIANS
MAKE AND EXPECT THE SAME RESULTS
BUT WE CAN WATCH CAREFULLY AND
LEARN FROM WHAT THEY ARE DOING